une vie de luxe apportée de main nager
dans l'opulence nager dans l'opulence
vous êtes travailleur fiable je vous
nomme directeur général
je crains de devoir refuser c'était mon
rêve en arrivant ici mes objectifs sont
différents aujourd'hui je suis différent
le compte développer ma propre affaire
club de strip-tease pour les femmes
à poil j'ai un truc à te dire Paul les
femmes aussi peuvent être excitées
bienvenue au chippendales
je suis fan de cet endroit vous avez
besoin que je travaille ici il faut un
chorégral
[Musique]
Ie
en ouvrir partout dans la Russie la
Chine me monte entier répète après moi
tout marche merveilleusement bien tout
marche merveilleusement bien et je ne
vais pas tout faire foirer et je ne vais
pas tout faire foirer veuillez applaudir
monsieur chippendale
c'est ma création c'est moi qui l'ai
engagé toi et moi on se serre les coudes
où on entre
c'est une promesse il va tout faire pour
t'écraser tout ce que j'ai gagné je l'ai
investi dans ce club
ça me gêne pas que tu fasses des trucs
louches
mais je te permettrai pas de les faire
n'importe comment
ça va saigner
il faut appeler la police
monsieur
j'ai tout et je ne regrette rien je vais
réduire cet endroit ensemble
vous êtes une mauvaise personne monsieur
bonheur Jean et vous n'avez encore rien
vu